[Applause]
collapsing struggling for breath and
foaming at the mouth
when the nerve agent sarin was used
against people in syria the world
watched on in horror
but the west failed to retaliate
russia repeatedly blamed terror groups
for the atrocities and the u.n security
council has now addressed concerns
russia is creating a similar false
pretext ahead of a chemical attack in
ukraine
russia asked the security council for
today's meeting for the sole purpose
of lying and spreading disinformation
and that is exactly what you have heard
from the russian pr this morning
russia's misinformation offensive
continued at the u.n its representative
waving images of the maternity hospital
in mariopol in a feeble attempt to
rewrite russia's brutality
russia has today
brought into the security council
a series of wild
completely baseless
and irresponsible conspiracy theories
let me put it diplomatically
they are utter nonsense pressure is now
on president biden to respond i'm not
going to speak about the intelligence
but but uh russia would pay a severe
price of the u.s chemicals
while the white house has announced new
measures to tighten the economic vice on
russia there's a sense of paralysis in
the west's response beyond sanctions u.s
intelligence has been largely accurate
in preempting putin's almost every move
when it comes to this invasion calling
out russia's plans publicly in a bid to
try and prevent them the west is clearly
worried about what putin will do next
what the west wants is for putin to
worry about how they would respond
the inescapable truth in all this is the
president along with western allies are
unwilling to confront russia militarily
for fear of a wider war in europe
president zielenski increasingly
frustrated that without more involvement
from nato there's nothing to deter putin
because we've been repeatedly convinced
if you want to know russia's plans look
at what russia accuses others of
russian strikes are getting ever closer
to nato's soil amid growing concerns of
a chemical attack the big question is
how the west would respond
sally lockwood sky news washington